in my last video I showed you how to
implement Redux patterns and angular
using ng rx store if you're brand new to
redux I recommend checking out that
video first if you haven't already if
you're an angular firebase Pro member
I'd like to take a second to say thank
you for supporting this project and let
you know that we're using your
investment to support other open-source
projects such as ng rx I pledged $100
per month and will do the same for other
exceptional angular projects and content
creators getting back to this episode
we're going to build an ng rx angular
app that uses firebase on the backend
we'll be able to retrieve as well as
update post on the firebase real-time
database when working with firebase we
have to worry about the side effects
that come with working with a third
party API ng Rx has a package called
effects that serves just this purpose we
can install it using NPM at this point
you should have angularfire 2 for
firebase installed you can find
instructions for that on the official
repo now let's look at why we need to
use effects in the first place
consider the following example of a pure
function it's considered a pure because
it only affects data within its own
scope it would be considered impure if
we defined a variable
outside of that function and then used
it inside the function scope what often
happens in the real world is we have an
impure function that will do an
operation on the database causing a
chain of different side effects in the
application the goal of ng rx effects is
to isolate functions like this to make
them behave more or less like a pure
function let's start coding this up in
angular in the app module we're going to
need the angular fired database as well
as the effects module store and store
dev tools then we're going to create our
own post effects and post reducer in the
upcoming steps post effects behave just
like an angular service so when we
import them we add them to an array and
the effects module then the reducer is
added to the store module now before
going any further I want to show you how
I have this app organized I have a
folder for actions effects models and
reducers you'll most likely want a
similar organization to this for each
feature in your app now let's get
started building the post model this
will just be a simple typescript
interface that defines the post itself
the push key will be the actual firebase
push key and then we'll have a
loading statements of bullion then text
votes and an optional airfield now we
can start building the post actions
we'll start by importing the action
interface from ng rx and also the post
model that we just created to create an
action we'll first export a constant
with the action name then we create a
class that will handle that data payload
for that action in order to get a post
from firebase we need to first supply it
with a push key string which we can do
by supplying it in the constructor for
this action when we make a get request
for a post it's asynchronous we don't
know if it's successful right away so
we'll create another action called get
post success that will fire once the
post is actually successfully retrieved
for the Vote actions which are conducted
with a firebase database update will do
a success and a fail action to handle
those two possible States when we
successfully retrieve a post we can send
that as the payload to update the data
store and we'll follow the same basic
process for all the other actions this
will make a little more sense when we
get to the effects and actually start
sending data through these actions the
final step is to export all these
classes as a single type so we can
strong type them when we get to the
effects but before the effects will
build the reducer function in the
reducer function we will import the post
actions we just created as well as the
post model we created earlier then we'll
set the post actions as a single action
type in the post reducer we pass the
state and the action as arguments then
to copy the old state to the new state
we're gonna use a new JavaScript syntax
called spread first we create an empty
object and then we put other objects
inside of it with three dots in front of
them and this will compose a new object
from left to right when we first trigger
the get post action will set the loading
state to true when the post returns
successfully we can add the action
payload to the object and also flip the
loading state to false and we'll follow
the same basic logic for the vote
actions and you might notice how concise
and readable our code is with the spread
syntax however keep in mind it's just a
proposal for es7 and it's not a fully
standardized feature in JavaScript as of
the making of this video now we can
finally start building our post effects
effects work just like an angular
service so we'll use the injectable
decorator
and then we'll import effects actions as
well as the angularfire database and
then a few rxjs operators as well which
you'll see in use here in a second and
lastly we'll import our post actions the
first step is to add the actions as well
as the angularfire database in the
constructor then you create an effect by
first using the effect decorator then
you strong type its value as an
observable action then you call actions
of type and the type being the action
that you want to perform in this case of
OU BR get post action in this case we
need to first map the payload down to
something that we can use since we've
strong typed all our actions we can just
map it down to the action type for get
post in this case the payload we're
sending it is a firebase push key that
we can use to retrieve the post from the
database in this example I'm using an
rxjs delay of two seconds just to show
the spinner in the UI that's not
necessary in real life so now we can use
merge map to take that payload of the
firebase push key to send the actual get
request to firebase we call DB object
payload and then we map that down to the
post that it returns and then we can
actually update the state in the
datastore and we can do that by just
returning the post actions get post
success when we trigger this action on
the front end it's going to look
something like this we get a two second
delay and then the post data is updated
in the datastore reflecting in the UI
now let's build a another effect to
handle the voting action it's the same
basic process to start but this time
it'll be a type of vote update then
we'll map it down to the payload just
like we did with the last effect but the
difference is when you do a firebase
update it's not actually an observable
rather it's a promise
but we can treat it like an observable
by putting it inside the of operator
then we can simply make the update call
the firebase like we would normally by
calling DB object with the push key and
then we'll update the votes to the new
value specified in the payload then we
can map the observable to the vote
success action and if there's an error
we can catch it and trigger the post
actions vote fail which will set the
optional error property on the datastore
to this error message now let's actually
put these effects to use in the app
component
we import ng rx store as well as our
post actions and post model then the app
state interface will just be defined as
the post and just like we did in the
last video we'll set the post isn't
observable and we'll inject the store in
the constructor now all we have to do is
create a couple event handlers that will
trigger these actions to get a post from
firebase I'm just going to hard code a
push key that already exists in the
database then to update the votes I'm
going to pass the existing post object
along with the new value we want to set
the votes at and then we can dispatch
the action and pass it the post and the
new value for the votes in the app
component HTML we just need to unwrap
the post observable and then we can bind
everything to buttons that we need to
trigger the get post action as well as
the vote update action and then we also
display a loading spinner conditionally
if the post is loading to distinguish an
upvote from a down boat we just pass it
the number one or the number negative
one if it's a down vote in a real app
you probably want to have some way to
validate that a boat belongs to a user
but in this case I just want to show you
how to actually make the update and
firebase you can see when we click the
upload or download button firebase is
being updated over here on the right and
we're observing the actual data in the
datastore so it's completely decoupled
from firebase if you installed Redux dev
tools in the last video you'll be able
to get a nice tree presentation of the
state as it changes so first we have a
blank state then it goes to the loading
state and then post data is loaded and
each time we vote we get a new state
tree as your app grows more complex this
can be extremely helpful for debugging
that's it for ng rx effects with
firebase if this video helped you please
like and subscribe and if you want to
support the channel consider becoming a
pro subscriber at angular firebase comm
looking a free copy of my book as well
as one on one project consulting thanks
for watching and I'll see you soon
you
[Music]